It doesn't look like iron for a stone monument.It's an
unusual shape, but on the other side of the glass there's something
written on it that looks like it tastes like a drink.But I don't think anyone will
read it.Please
put some effects on it.Other than
that, as expected.  It's not as big as a silver coin, but maybe it's a gold coin, or a gold coin.I don't know what to do
with soy milk.I don't know what's going on with
this narrow hole and the indentation with the transparent lid.The
effects are different.Get the effect conversion with the function.  If I do
that, I can deal with it.Hmm, seriously, wait a minute.The
100 points I used are
enough.The
number has increased, but I
haven't raised the price.I'm
saying that the monetary unit of this world is over.It's
expensive, but I'm tall and hungry.  I can't change it,
can I? [Music] Should I press this? Hmm, then there's a
picture of soup on it. If you
put your hand in it, you'll be eaten. That's weird. I
won't do it. So hurry up and
get it. This corn soup is mine.
[Music] Is it
really warm? I
wonder if I should just twist the lid.
[Music]
This is delicious. I can't compare it to the Messiah I use. I wonder what makes me so
happy. If I could
get it, I'd sell it automatically.  It's all about machine cooking. It's
almost gone. It must
be delicious. The
clear one is water, but I drank this bright
brown drink, and it turned red. People seemed to
like the milk tea, too.
Even more after that.  He bought me 3 corn soups and 1 bottle of water.
[Music] I
earned 30 silver coins, 6,300
won, and recovered 63 points.
[Music]